اعلنت هيئه الاركان الوكانيه ان قواتها
قصفت يوم امس منطقه تمركز للقوات الروسيه
داخل الاراضي الاوكرانيه
وسته مواقع للعتاد والافراد ومستودعات
وقود روسيه اضافت الهيئه ان الجيش الروسي
نفذ خلال الساعات الماضيه غاره جويه واحده
اضافه الى 20 رشقا براجمات الصواريخ
من جهه قال المتحدث باسم هيئه الاركان
الاوكرانيه من القوات الروسيه تواصل الضغط
على السكان في مناطق سيطرتها بمقاطعه
الزبرجها جنوب البلاد الاساسيه ما في
مدينه ان انجو انجو دار حيث اجبرت نحو
ثلاثه الاف عامل في محطه
النوويه على استخراجه وازاله السفر
الروسيه كما منع التداول العمله
الاوكرانيه في المدينه
رشيش كده توصل القوات الروسيه الضغطه
النفسيه والجسديه على السكان المدنيين في
الاراضي المحتله في مدينه في منطقه
زباروجيا اجبرت قوات الاحتلال الروسيه
حوالي 3000 عامل من محطه زبرجيا للطاقه
النوويه على الحصول على جوازات السفر
الروسيه تم اخراج العمله الاوكرانيه من
التداول في المدينه من خلال تهديد رجال
الاعمال بالغرامات ومصادره الممتلكات
وازداد عدد المباني السكنيه التي استولى
عليها المحتلون بعد ان هجرها سكانها بشكل
كبير